[Musique]
ça les enfants soyeux encore nounours
mais patron je vous répète qu'il ya
quelque chose de brillant qui nous suit
dans le cher le voyant au nord tu sais
bien que nous ne sommes pas les seuls à
voyager dans le ciel qui a des avions il
y à des fusées avec des cosmonautes qui
vont vers la lune le pauvre il y a aussi
des oiseaux qui font de longs voyages
dont les yeux brillent dans la nuit
j'aime mieux ça mais c'est tout de même
curieux et bien moi je descends chez mes
petits amis m'ont l'échelle europe hop
hop hop hop hop hop au
[Musique]
gmat un beau soir
au hall et d'ornement ils ont failli me
faire peur avec leurs fusils
face à grenoble
ma parole c'est un télescope qui compta
il est pour toi c'est formidable et bien
au travail
nous allons voir ce qui se passe dans le
ciel
tu vois quelque chose l'eau encore
écoute il faut mettre une manne de van
halen est regardée avec l'autre
c'est bien ce que je fais mais je le
vois rien c'est tout noir
c'est devant l'autre qu'il faut mettre
ta pas au me fallait le dire
mais je n'y vois rien
rien
aux je n'y comprends rien
je vais je vois où la lutte au noir
oui je t'ai rien ou
où
nous dit oh que ce joli j'aurais puis en
sus
[Musique]
des enfants
c'est une étoile une ravissante petite
étoile une étoile filante
le voilà bel s'approche de notre nuage
ils se sont en effet peut-être que vous
des pensions mais peut-être région est
sans doute de l'effrayant
je remonte sans faire de bruit nous on
va au lit doucement comme ça si tu la
vois tu lui diras qu'elle peut venir
chez nous n'oublie pas à demain bonne
nuit les enfants
[Musique]
bonne nuit connard
tom pyatt apprenait
[Musique]
pas trop je sais qui nous suit une
petite étoile filante
je les ai vus nounours tout à l'heure
elle est venue tout près de notre nuage
puis elle a filé la coquine et moi qui
m'inquiète un an route bonne yeux des
enfants à demain bonne nuit petite
étoile
[Musique]
oh